my colleague Jordan Peterson
is being investigated by the Ontario
College of psychologists
and he's being investigated by them he's
being threatened by them
they are suggesting that they might
take away his license to practice
psychology
because Jordan
tweeted against political correctness
basically he announced the other day
that the Ontario College of psychologist
has demanded that he submit himself to
mandatory Social Media communication
retraining
and with their experts for among other
crimes retweeting the Canadian
conservative leader and criticizing
Justin Trudeau the big lib who's running
Canada and some people are saying the
son of Fidel Castro I would never
suggest such a thing uh because he did
that because Jordan has tweeted and
supported the conservatives against the
Liberals they want him to be re-educated
they want to send him to a re-education
camp or
he says he will face an in-person
tribunal and suspension of his right to
operate as a licensed clinical
psychologist
Preposterous of course now they're not
going to destroy Jordan Peterson's
career Jordan Peterson will be just fine
he's not going to starve if they take
away his license to practice psychology
but on people who don't have
multi-million best-selling books and
world tours and shows and movies and all
the rest of it
this kind of power the power of
credentialism could destroy somebody's
life and career
some of you maybe many of you listening
to this show today
have very possibly faced this kind of
question especially during covid
even even outside of covid though if you
don't say the right thing if you don't
do the right thing then you're going to
be blackballed from your job then the
licensing or credentialing organization
they're not going to give you your
license then the university is not going
to give you what has become the basic
credential of operating in our our
liberal culture you need to have the
four-year college degree what do you
need to have learned nothing what what
skills you need to have acquired
absolutely none but you need to have
that credential or you're not allowed to
be admitted to the very special club to
work in all the fancy jobs in our
culture
it's a problem of credentialism now
it this underlines A movement that you
have seen for a long time on the
American right
which is that we have every day that
passes less and less respect for these
kinds of credentials this was not always
the case this is actually a trend that
is going on and people call it populism
and people call it anti-intellectualism
it it's not that
it's not our fault it's not the
conservative's fault it is the fault of
the people who Dole out the credentials
for squandering their own credibility
it's not not my fault that a Harvard
degree or Yale degree or a Stanford
degree
doesn't mean what it used to mean
50 70 years ago the New York Times used
to report on the outcomes of Yale
political union undergraduate debates
today
at the Yale political union and similar
sorts of debating societies students
will whine and cry and throw a hissy fit
if Kristen Wagoner a pro-life
pro-religious Freedom lawyer shows up
and explains the law in fact actually I
want to be fair it wasn't the Yale
political union where that incident
occurred it was at the Yale law school
this was graduate students this was the
professional students who were supposed
to be lawyers whining crying basically
throwing a riot because someone has a
different opinion it's not the fault of
the conservatives now who mock all of
the elite credentials
it's the fault of the elite institutions
which have squandered all of their own
credibility
and I I right now we're at this this
difficult point where people are getting
squeezed because the credentials still
kind of matter there is still some power
in them but people know it's all kind of
hollow and bogus but it still sort of
matters I very much look forward to the
day
where
a psychologist will not need the
approval of the Ontario College of
psychologists
who are who are have revealed themselves
to be nothing more than a leftist
activist organization to practice
psychology
or of of any of these other gatekeeping
institutions that have been totally
captured by the left that have that have
crawled in like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers hollowed out the guts of what
these institutions used to be and now
they're walking around
pretending that they still have
authority they don't we the only way out
is through there's no going back to
those good old days okay you the the
only way that you're going to achieve
good old days from good new days rather
is by by pushing through and saying
screw it who cares who cares what the
Ontario College of psycho if I want to
talk to Jordan Peterson and have him try
to fix my brain I'm going to do it
whether the Ontario College of
psychologist wants to or not and and the
Canadian government wants to come after
him for doing that well maybe it's time
that we have a little less respect for
the Canadian government and all of these
other
liberal totalitarians who who want to
who want to banish any sense of reason
and tradition and normal life from our
society we are heading over to the
member block right now so do not go
anywhere
unless you're not a daily wire member
then you've got to head on over to
dailywire.com right now subscribe become
a member we'll see you over at the
member block
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]